it's free comic book day uh which is a
nationwide celebration of comic books of
reading superheroes and everything that
falls into that world of comic books and
it's a huge celebration the movies and
the tv shows starring superheroes and
comic book characters have been huge for
the comic book industry and for our
business in particular shows like the
walking dead
cartoons like invincible disney plus
everything they've been really great for
feeding into bringing customers into the
comic book store free comic book day
happens as an annual tradition that
happens every year that's been going on
for 20 plus years now last year we
didn't have a free comic book day
because of the pandemic and everything
going on
so this year the anticipation is through
the roof people are so excited to come
by there's free comic books you'll see
superheroes in costume
tons of photo opportunity and at our
stores we're doing a charity charity
drive for the las vegas avengers and
critical care comics so there's a ton
going on at our shops and at stores
nationwide